HEY, BRET.
>> Bret: GOOD EVENING, WELCOME
TO WASHINGTON I’M BRET BAIER AND
BREAKING TONIGHT SERIOUS CHARGES
AGAINST THE ST. LOUIS COUPLE WHO
SAY THEY WERE JUST DEFENDING
THEMSELVES WHEN THEY DISPLAY
THEIR WEAPONS AS PROTESTERS
MARCHED PAST THEIR HOME LAST
MONTH.
AND HAPPENED SHORTLY AFTER THE
GEORGE FLOYD KILLING IN
MINNEAPOLIS AND IGNITED THE
FIRESTORM OF RACIAL UNREST
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY YOU
REMEMBER THE PICTURES AND THE
IMAGES THAT WE HAVE SEEN THE
COUPLE NOW BEING CHARGED CHIEF
BREAKING NEWS CORRESPONDENT
TRACE GALLAGHER HAS THE BREAKING
DETAILS TONIGHT AND GET EVEN,
TRACE.
>> ON JUNE 5TH CONFRONTED THE
ST. LOUIS PROTESTERS AND NOW
CHARGED WITH UNLAWFUL USE OF THE
WEAPON IN THE COUPLE HAVE NOT
BEEN ARRESTED WILL BEGIN TO GET
A NOTICE TO APPEAR IN COURT.
IF EMILY M GARDNER WROTE IN PART
"MY OFFICE FILED CHARGES AGAINST
THEM FOLLOWING THE INCIDENT
INVOLVING PEACEFUL UNARMED
PROTESTERS ON JUNE 28TH.
IF IT IS ILLEGAL TO WAIVE
WEAPONS IN A THREATENING MANNER
TO THOSE PARTICIPATING IN
NONVIOLENT PROTESTS AND WHILE
WE’RE FORTUNATE THE SITUATION
DID NOT ESCALATE INTO DEADLY
FORCE, THIS TYPE OF CONDUCT IS
UNACCEPTABLE IN ST. LOUIS."
SHE SAID SHE DECIDED ON CHARGES
AFTER A THOROUGH INVESTIGATION
BY THE ST. LOUIS POLICE BUT THE
POLICE ALSO REPORTEDLY FOUND THE
WEAPONS WERE NOT LOADED.
THAT THE GUN WASN’T EVEN REAL.
THE ATTORNEY FOR THE COUPLE’S OF
THE WERE "DISHEARTENING" AS I
UNEQUIVOCALLY BELIEVE NO CRIME
WAS COMMITTED AND THE MISSOURI
GOVERNOR MIKE PARSON HAD SAID
THAT IF CHARGES AGAINST THE
COUPLE WERE FILED, HE WAS
PREPARED TO EXERCISE HIS PARDON
POWERS.
THE GOVERNMENT WENT ON TO SAY
EVEN WITHOUT A PARDON, THEY
COUPLE WOULD LIKELY NOT BE DOING
ANY JAIL TIME AND THE PROSECUTOR
TODAY APPEARED TO BACK IT UP
CLAIMING THAT SHE SAYS SHE
BELIEVES THE BEST COURSE OF
ACTION HERE IS FOR THE COUPLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN A DIVERSION
PROGRAM WHICH IS DESIGNED TO
KEEP THEM OUT OF THE COURT
SYSTEM.
SO FAR, WE HAVE NOT HEARD